das tagesgespräch bei phoenix mit
professor clemens fuest vom ifo institut
für wirtschaftsforschung grüße sie ganz
herzlich in münchen
guten morgen herr coole gut dass wir uns
haben oder dass wir so eine gut genährte
nation sind oder naja es war schon
richtig in der krise die wirtschaft zu
stützen als die krise ausbrach mit
krediten einzugreifen und auch jetzt in
den sektoren in denen schließungen nach
wie vor da sind den unternehmen zu
helfen das ist schon richtig nicht nur
wegen der konjunktur sondern auch aus
fairnessgründen wir legen ja diesen
sektoren gastronomie hotels reisebranche
messebau einiges auf und da ist es schon
richtig zu helfen klar die
staatsverschuldung steigt an aber ich
denke auch es ist das geringere übel
hier dagegen zu halten natürlich muss
man immer wieder kritisch fragen sind
die maßnahmen zielgenau aber vom
gesamtbild her ist es schon richtig hier
gegen die krise zu halten
die hat dann haben sie sich schon ihre
nächste frage selbst gestellt sind sie
denn zielgenau
sie sind teilweise zielgenau zum
beispiel die verschiedenen hilfen für
die betreffenden branchen die sind
meines erachtens richtig weniger
zielgenau sind so dinge wie die
allgemeine mehrwertsteuersenkung das hat
meines erachtens wenig gebracht das ist
ja jetzt auch ausgelaufen deshalb eben
den unternehmen die hohe umsätze machen
aber das sind wir nicht die den wir
helfen müssen
insofern hat das viel geld gekostet und
meines erachtens relativ wenig gebracht
aber die direkt auf die betroffenen
branchen zielenden hilfen sind im großen
und ganzen richtig die detailgestaltung
darüber kann man reden auch über die
frage ob das ganze schnell genug
angekommen ist da hat sicherlich
probleme gegeben aber das sind im
prinzip richtige hilfen auch so dinge
wie verlust zurück trat bei unternehmen
das hat man schon richtig gemacht das zu
erweitern nicht genug aus meiner sicht
aber
es gab waren schon eine ganze reihe von
maßnahmen dabei die vernünftig waren
wenn dann heute der wirtschaftsminister
mit vertretern der verbände der
wirtschaft zusammen trifft da wird es
heiße diskussionen geben oder was
glauben sie
es ist ganz klar dass die wirtschaft
darauf besteht dass hilfen wirklich
ausgezahlt werden das ist mittlerweile
auch größtenteils passiert darüber
hinaus vertritt natürlich jeder verband
die eigenen interessen also etwa die
nicht lebensmittel einzelhändler wollen
natürlich öffnen
das problem ist aber dass wir die
sozialen kontakte begrenzen müssen damit
die infektion nicht ausufern und die
politik muss entscheiden reduzieren wie
soziale kontakte jetzt er beispielsweise
in der schule oder im einzelhandel und
da würde ich es zb schon verstehen wenn
der wirtschaftsminister dann sagt leute
tut mir leid aber wir legen jetzt ein
schwerpunkt auf die schulen letztlich
sind das aber politische entscheidung
es ist legitim wenn jeder einzelne
verband hier seine interessen vertritt
die politik muss allerdings aus ganze
achten ja und die politik kündigt schon
an und redet sehr umfangreich darüber
wie der nächste locker und ausfällt wie
hart und wie umfassend womit rechnen sie
und was heißt das für uns
es ist ganz schwer erwartungen darüber
zu bilden was jetzt passiert weil ja die
ministerpräsidenten alle
unterschiedliche auffassungen haben und
es ist ja wirklich fatal dass wir die
osterferien haben vorbeiziehen lassen
ohne die für eine reduzierung sozialer
kontakte zu nutzen da sind ja die
schulen zumindest teilweise sowieso zu
ich rechne damit dass man in der tat
noch mal die lok tor maßnahmen
verschärfen muss ebenfalls bedauerlich
ist allerdings dass wir nicht mal genau
wissen wie sich die infektion derzeit
entwickeln weil nicht gemeldet wird und
da ich glaube alters zeigt dass ein
wirklich überzeugendes proaktives
pandemie management in deutschland nach
wie vor fehlt und zwar mehr als ein jahr
nach ausbruch der pandemie das ist
gravierend umso wichtiger ist es jetzt
dass man nochmal eine anstrengung macht
und mit homeoffice mehr testen und
vielleicht auch noch mal verbessert hat
datenerhebung
und einer reduzierung sozialer kontakte
wo immer das nun passiert die infektion
noch mal herunter bringt bis die
impfungen uns wirklich wirklich helfen
das wird eben noch ein bisschen dauern
da sprechen sie zwei punkte an
testpflicht home office pflicht da
jammert aber die wirtschaft ja es ist
richtig aber wir müssen die
infektionszahlen herunterbringen es gibt
untersuchungen etwa vom ifo-institut die
ziemlich klar zeigen das home-office
hilft gegen die verbreitung der
infektionen jetzt ist es schwierig home
office wirklich per zwang zu
verschreiben weil jeder jede tätigkeit
ist anders und letztlich müssen die
unternehmen beurteilen wo es home office
möglich beim testen kann man aber in der
tat noch mehr machen auch hier strengen
sich viele firmen sehr an
wichtig ist dass getestet wird diese
debatte darüber wer die tests jetzt
bezahlt halte ich für unglücklich man
könnte es einfach so machen dass man den
unternehmen einen pauschalen zuschuss
zahlen zu den tests und dann wäre dieses
hindernis vom tisch es geht ja einfach
darum dass wirklich mehr getestet wird
und dass wir so mehr infektionen
entdecken und es schaffen die
infektionszahlen runterzubringen dann
sowas nochmal die frage sind sie für
einen harten lockdown einen der noch mal
richtig alles ausbremst ich bin dafür
ein die die sozialen kontakte zu
reduzieren dieses wort hat er noch
dauert ist irre führen wir werden nicht
die gesamte wirtschaft und das gesamte
soziale leben schließen
aber wir müssen die sozialen kontakte
nochmal reduzieren ob das jetzt im
bereich des einzelhandels passiert oder
ob man in den schulen noch einmal mehr
macht das ist letztlich eine politische
entscheidung aber ja wir müssen die
sozialen kontakte nochmal reduzieren
damit wir die infektion herunterbringen
denn sonst wird es auch keine
nachhaltige wirtschaftliche erholung
geben wir bleiben sonst im jojo lockdown
in den uns die politik jetzt leider
geführt hat weil sie eben nicht wie
früher eine überzeugende strategie
eingeschlagen hat sagt professor clemens
fuß danke schön für das gespräch mit
franken